so i think we go wrong
when people try to understand the world
around them and come up with
wrong ideas and and it it's it's it's
natural that they would come up with
wrong ideas
because it's hard to figure out what's
right so we start with trying to
come up with mystical explanations for
the for the for the existence of the
things around us
and that i think very quickly leads to
some people being able to communicate
with the
mystical stuff out there and some people
not being able to communicate and some
people
wanting to control other people and
using those
pseudo explanations as a way to control
so you always have
a rant called it attila and the witch
doctor you always have a witch doctor
the mystic the the the philosopher the
the intellectual the philosopher
you know king is a unity and you have an
attila you have somebody who wants
control of the people
who's willing to use force to control
other people and when those two get
together
that's when things go bad and
unfortunately
95 98 of human history is when those two
are together
and uh and and so the the the not having
them together having the right ideas and
the right ideas are ones that are not
exclusive
to those guys and where we don't allow
attila to have that kind of physical
power over us
that's an exception and that's rare and
that's
that's what needs to be defended
stalin's not personally killing people
hitler's not personally killing people
charles manson's not personally killing
people they need their goons
they need the goons but also they don't
they don't have original ideas nothing
stalin says is original to him
right he needs a mocks even lenin right
he
they all need a mocks right they all and
marx
needs a particular line of thinkers that
come before him
that that set him up for these kind of
ideas so
so he uh stalin both needs his goons
even though he's somewhat of a good
particularly stalin yeah as a bank
rapper
yeah and then so take lenin london i
think is a better example because
lenin's more
intellectual if you will but lennon
needs his goons he needs a stallions
but lennon also needs his marks and we
we don't want to let marks off the hook
because
marx knows i think implicitly that his
ideas have to
lead to lenin and stalin his ideas are
not neutral
i don't think it's implicit at all i
think mark's very much
glorified revolution blood and terror is
this is not
implicit no absolutely i mean there are
letters between him and angles where
they talk about which peoples will be
have to be
eliminated because they don't have that
proleteria
thing right so so i think the there's
certain certain peoples uh in southern
europe are not appropriate for
for for the utopia to come and will have
to be gone and marx also had this
concept
which we still see today in in in
garbled ways of poly logism which is
if you're a capitalist and i'm bourgeois
or i'm a worker
you just your logic is different than
mine it's literally gonna be impossible
for us to communicate
and at a certain point you're gonna have
to be liquidated and they pretend that
doesn't mean murdered but it means
murdered yeah and very quickly everyone
becomes the capitalist of bourgeois and
then you have
you know the the holodomor and things
like this no he knows exactly where it's
going to lead
and and this is why you know people say
oh marx is not evil he just wrote books
no
it's the people who write books who are
responsible for the way
people history evolves and they know
they know the bad guys certainly know
uh the consequence of their ideas and uh
and they need to bear the moral
responsibility for what
what happens when the idea is
implemented
you